world leaders at the g7 summit could be
ready to declare the raging wildfires
burning in the Amazon rainforest an
international crisis after dragging his
feet for a few days Brazil's president
appears to be responding to the
worldwide uproar by adding more boots to
the firefight Brazil contains about 60%
of the Amazon rainforest Kenneth Craig
is tracking the latest developments
Kenneth good morning well good morning
to you Dana the Amazon rainforest
produces a significant part of the
planet's oxygen and is a critical part
of containing climate change an
international outcry for a plan of
action has drawn brazil's president into
the spotlight and last night he
announced his plan in a televised speech
Brazilian president Jair bolson Oro says
he will be taking a tough approach to
battling the devastating fires burning
through parts of the Amazon bolson ro
who has reduced funding for
environmental agencies and relaxed
restrictions on logging promised to send
armed forces to the region to help douse
the flames wildfires are common in
Brazil during the country's dry season
which could last until November but
others are deliberately set by farmers
and loggers clearing the land but bolson
ro has suggested environmental groups
may be responsible for setting the fires
in retaliation for reduced funding from
his administration hundreds of
protesters marched the streets of Rio de
Janeiro to denounce the Brazilian
President as bolson ro announced the
military would join the fight against
the fires images of the fires have
spread around the globe sparking
protests outside Brazilian embassies in
South America and the United Kingdom and
international pressure is building on
Brazil from world leaders French
President Emmanuel macron plans to bring
Brazil's environmental crisis to the
forefront at the g7 leaders summit in
France this weekend Britain's Prime
Minister Boris Johnson and Germany's
Chancellor Angela Merkel have called the
fires shocking and threatening president
Trump tweeted yesterday that the u.s.
stands ready to assist an Brazilian
forces will start to deploy today to
areas in other affected regions France's
government accuses bolson ro of lying
about his environmental commitments and
said it would consider opposing a major
European European trade deal that would
benefit Brazil Jeff okay we're gonna
have more on the Amazon fires coming up
in just a little bit Kenneth thank you
very much